hi welcome to nerding out my name is
chastity and we're going to be talking
about things that we like and one of
those things is Doctor Strange the
latest movie from Marvel Studios I'm
here with my buddy Tony today let's jump
into some doctor strange talk alright so
first we have the Marvel movies have
been kind of you know action Avengers
Iron Man they're all kind of the same
thing this is a very different take on a
Marvel movie yeah I'm just range has
magic yeah so they're dirt I think
they're taking some risks I'm not doing
the same thing they have a successful
superhero formula but they're like bring
do magic we're gonna introduce whole
other corner and it worked the origin
will you know they got it down pretty
well he was an arrogant surgeon got in
the car accident hands ruined all that
was there what I felt the origin in the
movie it felt like it went kind of
quickly it did we're all sound powerful
too quickly yeah right and after I said
that to you then I was thinking like
well how much time really passed how
much time did he spend training cuz you
know they did show he was reading a lot
of books and he mentioned he's got a
photographic memory so maybe and then
the ancient one does say he's like oh
you got some innate ability beside you
it just seemed a little convenient like
convenient it just happened extremely
fast I would have liked to see that a
little more gradual I know they only had
X amount of time they did some
sputtering parts where he's trying to do
the reporting anything but yeah but this
is his struggle was so short then he
became super powerful evite Young fights
Mads Mikkelsen it's like wait instantly
it's just you do come on he killed his
other food and you're fighting them so
let's look about the cape Oh Anna Kate
be great cape was awesome I what's the
story behind the cape so it's a magic a
bit can do so but did it remind you of
anything else when you're watching it I
was reminded of another Disney property
oh oh wait Fantasia else thing we're
like Aladdin the rug like trying to do
that I mean at first I was like it's
again the humor yes there's Hugh nice
interior the same exact humor as the
carpet but it was cool yeah how it was
it how it helped them because that that
did add to the the part where he's not a
sore
supreme yet man he's fighting all this
stuff and like the cape was kind of
helping him Tracy you need to go over
here yeah it was humorous but it also
helped that he's not this expert eat
fighter you so why was he chosen by the
Cape maybe because what the ancient one
said that he's got this natural he was
destined you need a sorcerer supreme
like that [ __ ] the chosen one yeah he
gets the Cape it to me it seemed like
they broke the case and the capes like
all right thanks I'm gonna help you all
know this guy is he's less evil I guess
yeah and then he also had the eye of
agamotto agamotto I always said auger
motor they said Agema they said Agra
mota no I always get around so that that
was interested but it was there was a
pretty big spoiler with that which was
rumored which I guess we can talk about
it yes we could talk about it because I
mean that people suspected that was
gonna be one of the Infiniti safi and
they actually say it yes they're like
this one it actually said infinity stone
just go walking around with an infinity
sounds like dislike oh you can't make it
any clearer than that it's an infinity
stone it is so it is weird because dr.
strange he always has it but in the
movie he's like okay I'm gonna put it
back over here I'm gonna keep this rate
it's just gonna sit in this room not
guarded at all and I can walk through a
new street or describe no glass case or
anything I don't think that's very safe
yeah so we're talking about Doctor
Strange let's talk about some of the
other characters in this movie so we
have Mads Mikkelsen who is an incredible
actor but he's playing this extremely
super obscure your character who is this
XO cook Alyssia that case ilyas yes try
to find an image akai hana there's a
small little thing I think there's only
one panel it's like the blurry asst
thing right but he had this big role he
was kind of the main bill was the main
body throughout until maybe the last
quarter yeah and he was great great
actor so does add to it you know at
first it's like oh here's his bad guy
he's trying to ruin everything but he
does good performance you know you have
to define the villain by the performance
and right what are his goals he wants a
I don't even know what you want to
destroy to work you wonder mortality all
this stuff and the vision
were distracting enough in a good way
they're like okay maybe I don't need to
think so much about the whole plan so
his motivations were vague to me but the
action itself like he was a badass he
was very very threatening yeah and you
just could feel that he was going to
kick your butt yeah no matter what so so
he did the best he could with that
character so let's also talk about
Dormammu yeah so Dormammu is eventually
the Big Daddy oh yeah and that was a
surprise yes they didn't mention no
apparently you know who played dorama
know it was Benedict Cumberbatch I'm
pretty sure like a secret role is that
true I think that because i was seeing
that like Oh benedict her red doing this
other super other role and I was like
what other role and I was like we what
so he's talking to himself at the end I
think so days he did it a little
differently but cuz he had a great voice
yes Dormammu is like a big time like
probably his biggest villain and
wondered are like ok they're not going
with him they're going with this other
obscure guy but then they bring him in
so didn't you you do get a good scope of
like this guy is massive he's a powerful
other universe entity I wasn't sure what
they were gonna do with him or what they
could do with him but when I mentioned
him first in the movie I got excited
okay cool cuz I always equate you know
dr. strange with Dormammu and that's the
that's the clashing pair but I was like
yeah how are they gonna depict or mommy
but yeah he's kind of like this larger
than life but also it was it was a
little comedic as well because he was
stuck in a time loop yeah he's just like
what are you doing stop it yeah so yeah
we took up so he'll prob you back
someday even yeah he said he wouldn't
yeah I don't know he's a little more
threatening in the comics yeah yeah yeah
so yeah and then we have the ancient one
so in there was a lot of controversy
around this character because in the
comics it's an Asian man and we have
told a swinton playing the ancient one
so there was a lot of talk about
whitewashing the character which really
kind of angered me at first cuz I was I
was pretty pissed that they were going
with a white actor or actress for the
character but i think Tilda Swinton did
a good job with what she had and I'm
glad it was a woman at
if it was a white man i would be really
pissed at least I got a woman yeah
really fast I at least it was a woman
and she did a good job with what she had
but I feel like it would have been
extremely more progressive if they had
gotten an Asian definitely for the role
yeah it was interesting and I remembered
you know they did discuss like their
decision why they did it and how you
know there's been several different
ancient ones and they I think they were
saying they don't want to go too
stereotypical or I was like oh we're
like in you know whatever in this
country and you know so we got a hit so
it still seems like a missed opportunity
yeah it's extremely missed opportunity
but at least I like that it was a woman
you've been even greater if it was an
Asian woman that I would have been
really down for and also what was nice
is you know other difference is the
ancient one had a lot of action in the
comics to ancient one from what I recall
didn't really do a whole lot of hill
hangs back and just advises and she was
out there getting hardcored and kicking
butt and so so that was cool because
again it was weird weird direction we're
decision well matrix e yeah so it worked
but yeah I shown by why they could have
been done better yeah so we'll go with
that so let's talk about Christine
Palmer yes so in the comics what are the
differences with Christine so when the
comics Christine is night nurse so it's
basically rosario de Clare Clare
calculable and daredevil and with when
they did that character they told them
don't use night nurse because we want to
use that later but then Rachel McAdams
is not night night nurse she's a surgeon
and she kind of you eat photographer
yeah she she kind of does the role you
know she's does some superhero stuff so
whether she's gonna do that later we'll
have to see so at first i was little
concerned I was like that's it she's
gonna be out of the mind I'd like to see
more of her yeah or just more of her
outside of the hospital so she was
basically playing night nurse in this
yes and any shoes I feel like I need you
to fix me I need you to fix her yeah
she's like that's all I'm good for like
but I mean I love Rachel McAdams she's
great so it was nice that she did come
back she did have some other not huge
rolls but you know she was there it'll
be interesting to see how they use it i
mean is she just going to still be at
the hospital whenever he gets injury and
we
I would like to see her used for more
especially because it's rachel mcadams
and she's such a great actress yeah that
would be a waste so we have to end
credits scenes we have one mid-credits
scene in one very after the credits it's
seen let's talk about the last one first
is it tough it ties into the next sequel
yeah so in the next sequel so more dough
is left at the end and we see him go up
to Benjamin brats character and take
away his ability to her yeah and he take
us an hour away he says there's too many
too many sorcerers make sense so that
was a big difference for mortal because
in the comics he was there when one
doctor when Stephen strange first found
an ancient one yeah and then right away
pretty much you find out that he's kind
of a shady guide he wants a betrayed the
ancient one so it was weird that use
from the trailers everything you see
like oh these guys are almost like
buddies you know they're running through
the streets of New York together and
it's like they're really changing the
character and and you had a feeling that
you know he's gonna fall from grace and
all that so they set that up so now
because he's besides Dormammu mortals
probably like the second biggest Doctor
Strange villain so they set that up if
we said if in window dr. strange too and
that we can count on and he's gonna try
to take out all the sorcerers yeah yeah
alright and so let's talk about that
mid-credits scene which was super fun
and all the Marvel fans are gonna love
this scene because it's dr. strange
talking to Thor yeah and that was
surprised because they've mentioned i
think they confirm dr. strange will be
infinity infinity war avengers so we
knew that but now it seems like he said
up for a Ragnar yeah cuz they said
before it can be Thor and Hulk no
where's Hulk been since age of Ultron
right but now so they've just finished
wrapping thor ragnarok so somehow
Benedict Cumberbatch snuck onto the set
did that because I haven't heard
anything about him being here so that
pretty much I think confirms that he's
gonna play some role because he's like
you guys are kind of a threat to the
earthly plane it's like we need to get
you a tea yes I'll help you you and you
can leave
even go out of here so that'll be cool
yeah that's great i'm excited to see
some more Doctor Strange swimming with
other Marvel characters yeah very soon
so that'll be next ya next year yeah so
all in all Doctor Strange worth seeing
yes I recommend it yeah you recommend it
yeah I'm going to see it again great so
go check out dr. strange am i'm sure you
have already if you're watching this
podcast and for all your nerding out
check out gamespot universe